on en parle tout de suite avec notre
invité alexandre maulin président des
domaines skiables de france
alexandre blain bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin alors
c'est toujours le flou pas de nouvelle
date avancée le gouvernement attend
justement de disposer de recul sur les
données sanitaires liés aux fêtes de fin
d'année quelle est votre réaction ce
matin
écoutez son est profondément énervé on
ne comprend pas ce manque de visibilité
et en disant qu'on veut protéger les
vacances de février avec les
méthodologies qui nous est proposé là
sans vision on est en train de les
enterrer on est en train d'enterrer le
coeur de saison et de faire courir un
risque économique à l'ensemble de nos
territoires de montagne une date donc
avant les vacances de février c'est
crucial d'ouvrir à ce moment de l'année
il est crucial de pouvoir travailler en
février mais de pouvoir avoir généré des
réservations pouvoir du monde
est ce que ce serait dommage d'ouvrir et
qui est personnes en aux stations donc
si on ne nous donne pas une visibilité
qu'on n'ouvre pas dans les dix prochains
jours
on risque de en l'air les
vacances de février certains pays ont
gardé leurs stations de ski ouvertes on
a vu certaines images où il y avait
énormément de monde beaucoup de deux
queues devant les télésièges par exemple
est-ce qu'en france vous pensez que les
conditions de sécurité sanitaire sont
suffisantes
le ski est un sport de plein air et si
les files d'attentes pour une remontée
mécanique elle est en extérieur donc
avec le masque avec de la distance ni
entre les personnes quel est le risque
en plein air sinon faut supprimer toutes
les files d'attentes que l'on peut voir
dans les commerces en ville ou devant
n'importe quelle structure
aujourd'hui nous sommes des
professionnels et des professionnels
doivent s'adapter
nous sommes adaptés en écrivant au
niveau de l'ensemble de la station un
protocole qui courait l'ensemble du
parcours client mieux que ce qu'on
retrouve sur n'importe quel autre part
du territoire et c'est pour ça qu'on
arrive pas entendre cette volonté de
nous mais c'est fermé
on a vraiment l'impression d'être un
trophée essais ont eu toute une partie
du territoire c'est les régions de
montagne les départements de montagnes
et les vallées qui sont condamnées en
termes de déficit budgétaire est ce que
vous avez déjà en premier
ils ont un
voilà de cette saison sur la période des
vacances de noël l'association des
maires de stations de montagne a fait
ressortir que 70 % de la fréquentation a
été perdu c'est à peu près 80% du volume
d'activité puisque certaines professions
comme la mienne n'ont pas plu du tout
ouvrir donc aujourd'hui quand on ferme
les remontées mécaniques c'est moins 80
% de fréquentation et d'activités sur
nos territoires
c'est ça montre bien l'ampleur du drame
que l'on traverse
vous avez également reçu des aides du
gouvernement ce qu'elles sont
suffisantes pour les professionnels de
la montagne
aujourd'hui nous sur les domaines
skiables nous n'avons pas d'être pour
l'instant parce que nous avons réussi à
faire à montrer l'aspect cité de nos
métiers
mais il faut attendre un retour de la
commission européenne qu'on n'attend pas
avant la mi février donc aujourd'hui on
n'a rien on n'est pas sûr d'avoir et on
sait que pour les acteurs aujourd'hui
c'est bien insuffisant ce qu'ils ont par
rapport à la spécificité de la
saisonnalité que l'on a sur nos
territoires
il n'y a pas que le secteur de la
montagne qui est touchée où on a vu
évidemment le secteur de la restauration
les professionnels de la restauration
qui se sont fait entendre ils ont
protesté manifester ce que vous pensez
que vous en arriverais là justement à
faire des manifestations pour essayer de
rouvrir un veau vos stations ski nous
sommes prêts à tout pour faire de nos
territoires
donc aujourd'hui on prend le coup de
massue on s'est pris un camion dans la
file et grands soirs quand on nous a
donné ce manque de visibilité ce report
d'ouverture
maintenant nous allons nous organiser et
nous n'en resterons pas là car nous ne
voulons pas être condamné alors que nous
ne sommes pas coupables
merci beaucoup alexandre blain d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président des domaines
skiables de france